who the hell are you Nick Fury director
of shield I'm here to talk to you about
the Avenger initiative there was an idea
to bring together a group of remarkable
people happy holidays everyone we're
getting ready for some new infinity war
to drop so I wanted to do a video for
the theory of how they're going to sew
up the timeline in all these movies with
Captain Marvel going into infinity war
because it's all about the Avengers
initiative the whole concept of its
creation the way that Nick Fury talks
about things happening in the past and
now we know that the Captain Marvel
movie is going to take place in the past
so some of the events of the Captain
Marvel movie will set the stage for
things that we've seen already happen
and you'll have a big light bulb moment
like oh this is where he came up with
the idea for the Avengers initiative so
I'll explain the timeline but if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything
there's a whole bunch of comic book
stuff that's gonna drop really soon you
know doing a giveaway for replicas of
the Infinity Gauntlet that I'll explain
at the end of the video starting with
the Infinity war trailer what is the
most important thing that said during
that not by Thanos Thanos has that big
speech about you will know what it is to
lose the other big thing is Nick Fury
speech about the Avengers initiative
that each of the different characters
talked about because this is going to be
the 10th anniversary of Marvel Studios
but the next two Avengers movies are
meant to be the culmination of
everything that this universe has been
building towards since that first Iron
Man movie in the first Avengers movie so
like that post credit scene that I
attached to the beginning of the video
you're part of a bigger world it's Nick
Fury
telling him about the Avengers
initiative and then he actually gives
the speech during the Avengers movie
there was an idea stark knows this
called the Avengers initiative the idea
was to bring together a group of
remarkable people see if they could
become something more see if they could
work together when we needed them to to
fight the battles we never could during
that first Avengers movie when he's
addressing the council and they're
looking at different solutions to the
shatori invasion the council votes to
flat out nuke the city because they
don't think the Avengers initiative
will work but Nick Fury tells them
there's a program that I've been working
on my backup and he's trying to pitch
them the idea of using the Avengers
initiative to solve the problem meaning
that they've never tried something like
that before there's no older version of
the Avengers team this is something that
Nick Fury has been planning for a long
time implying that he had the idea for
the Avengers initiative a long time ago
so here's the idea
we know that Nick Fury is going to be in
the Captain Marvel movie he'll have both
of his eyes lost my one good eye
the Kree will be the villains of that
movie the Skrulls will be in a two
though kind of the villains because
they'll be doing Crees scroll war
she'll get her powers but the idea is is
that Nick Fury witnesses the scale of
this galactic war and decides there's
just too much out there for earth to
handle with his current resources so
because Captain Marvel is a military
person he probably has something to do
with her decision to stay out there in
police the galaxy so she's not around
for the events of phase 1 phase 2 in
most of phase 3 we're not gonna see her
on planet earth or in proximity to the
other Avengers till the fourth Avengers
film because like she might show up at
the tail end of infinity war they'll
probably like a post-credits scene but
then you go to the Captain Marvel movie
and that takes place in the past then
they jump back to present day with the
events of Avengers 4 although it looks
like there's a lot of flashbacks or
legit time-travel using the time gem
because they're wearing a lot of their
Avengers era costume so it's like wait a
minute
are they flashing back to the first
Avengers movie or are they actually
travelling back in time so just forget
about that for now the whole idea is
that Nick Fury sees all the craziness of
the kree-skrull war and what happens to
Captain Marvel recognizes that they need
something like the Avengers initiative
so he comes up with the idea and it just
continues to percolate for a number of
years but here's where they rope in one
of the biggest Easter eggs from phase 1
and phase 2 bringing people back to life
remember how they brought Coulson back
to life on agents of shield after the
Avengers movie the whole explanation for
that is that Nick Fury knew that
eventually he would lose one of the
Avengers in battle but because they were
so necessary he needed a way to put the
chess piece back
the board so they wanted a way to revive
dead Avengers in order to do that they
needed Kree blood so you wonder how long
has that Kree been down there they never
answered that question but the whole
idea is is that now they might just use
the Captain Marvel movie to explain
where Nick Fury 1 got the idea for the
Avengers initiative in the first place
and two got the Kree soldier put him on
ice and experimented on him to see if
they could use it to bring people back
to life because bringing it back around
to the Captain Marvel movie Nick Fury
probably sees what happens to Captain
Marvel as he loses his life and Captain
Marvel is minted in the process and
thinks to himself what horrifying fate
awaits the earth if people like that
fall in battle so he witnesses all this
comes up with the idea that's how you
get your agents of shield Coulson
revival and the whole concept of the
Avengers initiative there was an idea so
it's really just a nice way to book in
that Iron Man post-credit scene which
was essentially the beginning of the
Avengers universe like they'd had Marvel
movies before that but this was the
moment where they were coming out of the
woodwork and saying it literally we are
putting an Avengers team together even
though they didn't know if they'd ever
actually be able to do that but let me
know in the comments if there's any
other way that they bookend Marvel
Studios 10th anniversary and that
post-credit scene from the Iron Man
movie how would you want them to do it
it just feels like that's why they're
leaning so heavily on that Nick Fury
speech but it's a really nice way to
make Captain Marvel as a movie and a
character more relevant to the creation
of the Avengers like she in a way was
responsible for their creation even
though she wasn't around at the time but
she's still up in deep space while this
is all happening and if you're wondering
why I mentioned the death of Marvel so
in the comics Captain Marvel became
Captain Marvel after Marvel died the
previous version of the character so
eventually she took his name she used to
be called Miss Marvel recently it was
announced that they were pursuing Jude
Law to play dr. Walter Lawson who is
marvel in the comics so the idea is is
that he'll be a very Steve Trevor type
person inspiring Captain Marvel to
become Captain Marvel eventually but
having to die in order to do that so
whatever their adventure is it sounds
like he will die like he died in the
comics
they'll probably alter the way that he
dies because he died from cancer in the
comics which feels like a bummer way to
die in a big 150 million dollar movie
like this so it'll probably be some
noble sacrifice that he makes but
they're not actually gonna start
shooting the Captain Marvel movie until
early next year so we'll learn more
about that by the time we're ramping up
for infinity war two drop in theaters so
for those of you asking for more Captain
Marvel videos that's probably the time
of the year that I'll start doing those
there's a new round of that Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway all you have to do to
enter is just be a subscriber or leave a
Marvel related comment on the video
congratulations to the winner from my
last video Mason shorter please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for my new Deadpool
video and click here for brand new Rick
and Morty thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]